welcome to this video playing in mortal
in mortal okay i'm from argentina right
yes to 296 and i am what's name booster
for my yard yeah not quite sure where I
think there are thousands of
international masses no no way you no
way you are ever going to know the mall
okay this is slightly oops no Bishop
slide the uncommon line 26 it has a
quite bad reputation but lot for
tactical reasons just because um just
because the fianchetto here doesn't
really um work so well in this some
exchange Slav structure time I should
have played h3 really know that I think
of it but okay it's not not a big deal I
hope
maybe three Wow
94 this is a really ambitious this move
why would you do that okay let's let's
play normal moves to not spend too much
time it just looks like it loses time
because what what what else is this
night going to do besides taking on c3
and speeding up my see foul play yeah
yeah that's them there are many ways now
to play technical ways nitey 4d takes e
Bishop c7 is one of them with some yeah
wince a porn at the end yeah let's do
that
maybe
they can play be five maybe but ok i
just have quindi one it's it's not a
problem ok yeah yeah yeah i was thinking
what about Roxy 5 where's the screen
going Roxy 5 where is it going Queenie 6
the snide g5 and turned resins I think
okay so i could could actually take him
an assistance is the easiest to now take
on a five de Bishop 3 and b7 essa is
hanging badly if I just take it there
should be seven oxy five bc five Bishop
b2 rock do you one yeah this is this is
this upon the seaport is the hero of the
day and this this line will be a tosok
c7 so c 6 p-6 come on Bishop see Sapna
wins the exchange
yeah this is this is easier look to you
on the edge black resigns no no defense
yeah 94 really asked for trouble and
then then a six I know it's probably too
much already oxy one yeah the computer
wants to go knight c6 back with a clear
edge for white but not a win but this is
simply winning forward yeah it just
winning bishop see seven assists too
much this kind of idea b5 is the
relatively best defense according to
this to this engine but it shouldn't it
shouldn't save the day if I've yeah just
here takes and still of this yeah it's
it's at least upon at the end enter in a
big position allege g6 is a bit
surprising from a decently rated player
because it's really a well-known fact
that this is not not a good line this
Bishop is simply not well placed on just
having one point is that later if you
look at this kind of position quite
often hear the night for instance some
is useful here and the bishop is often
needed to defend the Queen side and on
g7 that's simply not doing much so this
is some quite comfortable structure and
as we saw on the game with just a couple
of more inaccurate moves you can easily
drift into a lost position alright
thanks for watching